the pushback that president biden is
getting in this latest effort to get
prices under control this morning's
national average by the way for gas is
4.94 cents a gallon
very high but actually down about a
nickel and two pennies from a week ago
partly due to lower oil prices and
partly due to america's just driving
less according to aaa now the president
thinks that prices will drop much more
if congress suspends the federal gas tax
but he's getting some serious resistance
on capitol hill including from democrats
ed o'keefe is at the white house force
tracking all of this ed what's happening
here well tony you might think lawmakers
want to help americans save some gas
money especially this close to the
midterm elections but as you said
democrats and republicans thrown up some
roadblocks saying this isn't a great
idea in part because it won't
necessarily save you as much as you
might expect
your customers
the american people they need relief now
if congress goes along with president
biden's calls for a three-month gas tax
holiday
the average price per gallon could drop
18 cents for regular fuel 24 cents for
diesel but that's assuming gas stations
and oil companies cut their prices
something they're not required to do
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product
do it now
how much could prices come down if it
costs nearly 75 dollars to fill up a 15
gallon tank on a typical small suv
suspending the gas tax would save only 2
dollars and 70 cents this is just a
gimmick we need to call it what it is on
capitol hill republicans who normally
support tax cuts say mr biden's proposal
is a short-term fix they want him to
push for a boost in domestic oil
production instead he needs to take his
foot off the neck of domestic producers
here in the united states that's
nonsense
industry has more approved permits for
production on federal lands than they
can possibly use and while some states
are already giving drivers a gas state
tax break as the president encouraged
many democrats doubt savings from a
federal tax holiday would help people
who could really use it economists like
mark zandy whose advice the president
has sought in the past are also
skeptical since the proposed plan could
potentially cost the highway trust fund
10 billion dollars we need to invest in
infrastructure and this will take away
from that potentially hurting a key
biden accomplishment we want to make
very clear
if we were to take this action
that
it's easy to take away attacks it's hard
to put one back on
and as somebody who as governor spent a
lot of time trying to
pay for virginia's infrastructure needs
sometimes not always successfully
i'm
hesitant
the president says that with tax
revenues overall
up and the deficit coming down there's a
way to temporarily fill the highway
trust fund with money from other parts
of the government while this suspension
would be in place we'll see about that
now today the energy secretary and other
biden administration officials are set
to meet with oil executives to talk
about driving gas prices down further
nate
ed thank you